franck et de bulles de responsables dans
les médecins spécialistes à la
confédération des syndicats médicaux
français bonjour
franck builder merci d'être avec nous
pourquoi est ce que vous redoutez une
vague de malades après le confinement
merci à vous monsieur petitjean alors
c'est pas seulement après le confinement
rappelons-nous le message envoyé par le
président la relique emmanuel macron le
lundi de pâques nous disant il n'y a pas
que le virus qui tue le renoncement aux
soins est également source de danger ce
message a été relayé par le directeur
général de l'assurance maladie nicolas
revel
puis hier ou avant-hier par notre
ministre de la santé lors du point
presse effectuée en compagnie du premier
ministre est le message que l'on porte
aujourd'hui c'est bien évidemment qu'il
convient de respecter les mesures
barrières bien évidemment que vit la vie
du coronavirus il faut faire preuve de
grande prudence et que les mesures de
confinement doit être maintenu comme on
nous l'a demandé jusqu'au 11 mai puis
les détendre et les progressivement et
des modalités sont en cours de
discussion au niveau politique mais bien
évidemment aussi qu'il ne faut pas
renoncer pour autant à tout soin ou
risque de se mettre en danger
s'il ya une nouvelle vague de malades
autre que le courant n'a virus donc
après le 11 mai et s'il ya une deuxième
vague épidémique de covin 19 qui
intervient car on l'a vu avec l'institut
pasteur aussi l'immunité collective
n'est n'est pas là est-ce que les
hôpitaux vont exploser entre le
confinement pas si difficile de faire
des prédictions sur l'avenir ont fait
que la crap en matière de ce que vous
appelez hôpitaux qui explose
c'était surtout la crainte que les
services de réanimation publics et
privés qui à la réanimation dans les
cliniques privées
évidemment puisse être dépassé par la
vague a claironné virus un peu comme on
l'a constaté dans le nord de l'italie
avec tant d'inquiétude
et c'est pour ça que tu es mesures de
confinement ont été prises avec tant de
vigueur et on peut que saluer les
français de les respecter pour que la
courbe de cette vague cours de
l'incidence de l'épidémie baisse et nous
permettent d'avoir toujours un petit
coussin
de deux places disponibles en
réanimation mais notre crainte c'est à
la fois le nombre des patients au cours
d'un virus mais le nombre de patients
après mais c'est surtout la gravité de
pathologique continuerait à évoluer avec
des patients confinés nous disant je
vois plus personne je reste chez moi je
vais même plus consulté mon médecin
il ya certainement des soins qu'ils
peuvent attendre parce que il ya des
pathologies qui peuvent attendre un peu
et d'autres pas du tout et pas que les
urgences et pas que la cancérologie qui
sont traités aujourd'hui
donc prudence fait vous soignez utiliser
les moyens modernes on utilise
aujourd'hui beaucoup la téléconsultation
qui peut se faire par visio qui peut se
faire par téléphone les gens qui sont un
peu moins d' alerte avec l'utiliser
d'âge de la vision ou dans des zones où
la la connexion internet est mou de
moins bonne qualité mais faites vous
soigner sont vite fait soigner mais
cette fois toutes les personnes ne vont
pas entendre ce message et elles vont
peut-être se ruer dans les hôpitaux
après le confinement à partir de cette
date du 11 mai qu'est ce que vous
préconisez pour éviter que les services
hospitaliers soit à nouveau surchargé on
le rappelle un avant la crise la france
étaient 5000 lits de réanimation n'est
monté jusqu'à douze ou quatorze mille je
crois alors que l'allemagne en avait 25
milles ils sont montés jusqu'à 40000 il
ya deux questions de votre question il
ya la question de comment craint-on et
comment on peut on prévenir une vague
brutale à partir du 11 mai je pense qu
aura pas de vague brutale de consulter
son nouvel à partir du 11 mai tout
simplement parce que les mesures de
déconfinement j'entendais monsieur blanc
caire en parler pour les écoles mais
c'est pareil pour tous tout les domaines
de notre vie vont se faire de façon
progressive et mesurée
on sait tous que faute d'un vaccin pour
l'instant et falloir attendre quelques
mois faute d'une nombre suffisant de
personnes qui ont rencontré le virus
l'immunité collective on n'y est pas
avec 5 6 7 % j'entendais 5 7%
l'ong met dans le reportage précédent le
mien donc il va il va falloir attendre
un peu
dans le message aujourd'hui c'est allez
vous faire soigner si vous avez d'autres
affections que coronavirus ne tardait
pas à le faire
s'étaient relayés par les politiques
l'assurance maladie
pleinement jouer ce rôle auprès de
l'ensemble des assurés sociaux
et puis en même temps faudrait dire il
va nous falloir respecter les mesures
qui vont être mises en place qui vont
être amenés à garder un certain nombre
de distanciation social de précaution de
port de masques certainement largement
répandue dans les transports publics en
particulier mais mais dans d'autres
domaines de la vie pour éviter d'avoir
une deuxième vingt que ce que le risque
c'est ça fait que cette deuxième vague
est à nouveau mettre à mal le service
hospitalier en particulier en ce qui
concerne la réanimation sur les tests
hier jérôme seulement le directeur
général de la santé à une question d'un
journaliste qui ai demandé combien de
test les autorités ont commandé pour
arriver aux femmes et 500 mille tonnes
d'ici au 11 mai il a répondu je cite
suffisamment qu'est ce que ça veut dire
et comment est ce que vous accueillez
cette réponse
la première mesure est de se protéger
la première mesure et que les choix
niant sa protégée que la population put
être protégés que quand on va se faire
soigner parce que tu es c'est là où est
la crainte on ne pige pas ceux
contaminés au contact d'autres patients
ou de houe de son médecin ou son
infirmière elle même malade concernant
les tests on sait qu'il ya deux types de
terre et les tests par pcr les tests
virologiques est-ce qu'on est porteur ou
pas du virus
on sait que on en a peut-être pas
suffisamment réaliser on sait aussi pour
le regarde et recul que au moment où on
se fait prélever 30 pensons il ya 30% de
tests qui sont faussement négatifs parce
que le prélèvement est insuffisant parce
que le test n'a pas pu encore se
positiver et que l'affection grandi et
puis à tout problème des tests ou toute
la avantages des sérologies donc allant
se faire tester par des tests plus ou
moins rapides là est obligé vers en a
parlé on manque encore de certitude
scientifique absolue pour avoir le choix
du bon test et de la stratégie
je pense qu'après il nous faudra tous et
que l'état nous y aident à tester le
maximum de patients pour que et le
maximum de français par des passions
pour qu'on puisse aller vers des mesures
de déconfinement de plus en plus large
merci from the builder d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
un représentant des médecins
spécialistes à la confédération des
syndicats médicaux français